The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: All right,
so I guess I should start.
So I think last time we
were talking about cell
structure and cell geometry.
And I got as far as
putting this image here up.
And I talked a little
bit about how this works.
And I was going to go
over it again and then
write the notes down today.
So we'll start from there.
So we're going to do a little
bit more on cell structure
today.
We're going to talk about
some topological laws
for cellular materials
for polyhedral cells.
And then we'll start talking
about modeling honeycomb
materials, and talk
about how we look
at the mechanical
properties of honeycombs.
So I think where we
left off last time was
we started talking about
mean intercept length.
So the idea is that
with-- hello, hello--
if you have a honeycomb, it's
fairly easy to define the cell
shape in terms of the ratio
of the cell edge lengths,
h over l, and the angle
that the inclined cell
wall is to the vertical one.
But for a foam it's a
little more difficult.
And what people do is they
measure this mean intercept
length.
So last time I talked
about it briefly.
So the idea is you take an
image of the structure you're
interested in.
You sort of draw out the
outline of a planar surface.
And then you put on
that a test circle.
And you superimpose on the
test circle equidistant
parallel lines.
So say we start off
at theta equals 0.
We then count how many
times the cell walls
intercept those lines.
And we get a number of
cells per unit length.
And that gives us an intercept
length for that orientation.
Then we rotate it
around a little bit,
say 5 degrees or something.
And we measure a new intercept
length for that orientation.
And we keep doing it all
the way around, 180 degrees.
And then you get--
then what you do
is you plot those points-- if I
can find my little pointer-- we
plot those points.
And it will form an ellipse.
And the major and minor
axes of the ellipse
correspond to the principal
dimensions of the cells
on that plane.
And then you can do the same
for perpendicular planes
and form an ellipsoid.
And you can get the three
principal dimensions.
You can also get the
orientation of the cells
by getting the orientation
of this ellipse,
or the ellipsoid in
three dimensions.
So let me just write down
some notes that kind of
summarize all of that.
So I'm going to say that for
foams, we characterize the cell
shape and orientation by using
these mean intercepts-- mean
intercept lengths.
So we consider a circular
test area on a plane section.
So you want to use a
circle and not say,
a square or a rectangle.
Because if you
had a square, then
you'd have different
total lengths of line,
depending on what
orientation you took it.
So you want to use a
circular test section.
And then you draw
equidistant parallel lines.
So for example you might
start at theta equals to 0.
And then you count the number
of intercepts of the cell walls
with the lines.
So if we say that Nc
is the number of cells
per unit length of line, then
we can get the intercept length
for that orientation.
Say for theta equals to
0, it works out to 1.5/Nc.
So it's not just 1/Nc,
because you may not
be cutting the cell--
you know, you're
cutting the cell-- say you've
got a three dimensional
cell like this.
You're cutting it at
different places along here.
So people have worked out
the stereology of that.
And there's a constant that's
1.5 that fits into there.
So then you just
repeat that process
for different
increments of theta.
So you increment theta
by some amount, something
like say, 5 degrees.
And then you repeat
that whole process.
And then you plot
a polar diagram
of the intercept
lengths versus theta.
And you then fit an
ellipse to the points.
And if you did it in 3D,
you'd have an ellipsoid.
And then the principal
axes of the ellipsoid
are the principal
dimensions of the cells.
And the orientation
of the ellipsoid
is the orientation of the cells.
Hello.
And you can write the
equation of the ellipsoid.
So it would be something
like Ax1 squared plus B
x2 squared plus Cx3 squared plus
2Dx1x2 plus 2Ex1x3 plus 2Fx2x3.
And that would all equal 1.
And you can write those
coefficients as a matrix.
And if you do that, the
first three, A, B, C,
are the diagonals, and D,
E, F are the off diagonals.
And you can also represent
this is a tensor.
And if you do, it's
called the fabric tensor.
So the fabric-- I think they
use that term for other types
of materials-- it says
something about the orientation
of the material.
And if you have
this matrix here,
if D, E, and F are all
of 0, then A, B, and C
are the principal
dimensions of the cell.
So if all non-diagonal
elements are 0,
then A, B, and C are the
principal dimensions.
Are we good with how this works?
So it's kind of a crank
and churn kind of thing.
But it gives you a
way of characterizing
the cell shape and
the orientation
of the cells in the foams.
So the next thing I
wanted to talk about
was the connectivity
of the cells.
So imagine we have
an array of cells.
And if we have an
array we have vertices
that are connected by edges.
And edges surround faces.
And the faces enclose the cells.
And there's something called
the edge connectivity, which
is usually given the symbol Ze.
And that's the number of
edges that meet at a vertex.
And there's a face connectivity,
and that's the number
of faces that meet at an edge.
And it's very common
for honeycombs
to be three connected.
So Ze is 3.
And it's common for foams
to be four connected.
And there's some
topological laws
that are kind of interesting.
And so we'll get into those
after this bit on connectivity.
So for the connectivity
we have vertices,
which are connected by
edges, which surround
faces, which enclose cells.
So we're going to talk about the
vertices, the edges, the faces,
and the cells.
So the edge connectivity,
Ze, is the number
of edges that meet at a vertex.
And for a honeycomb, say a
hexagonal honeycomb, Ze is 3.
So I have a little
honeycomb here.
If we look at the number of
edges, there's three edges,
connect at a vertex.
So Ze is 3.
And for a foam, Ze
is typically four.
So I'll just say typically here.
And if I go back, if you
look at the sketches here
of the rhombic dodecahedra
and the tetrakaidecadedra,
if you look at the
tetrakaidecadedra,
you can see the number of edges.
So here's one edge.
Here's another one here.
There's another one here.
And there's another one here.
So that's the four edges that
are meeting at that vertex
there.
So if you look at
arrays of cells,
you can convince yourself that
Ze is typically 4 for a foam.
And then we also have the
face connectivity, Zf.
And that's the number of
faces that meet at an edge.
And that's typically
three for foams.
And so again if you
look at these pictures
you can sort of see how the
face connectivity is three.
So if you look at this bottom
one here, there's faces here.
And then there's another face--
well, let's see if we can--
it's kind of hard to show.
If you look at this one
here, there's this cell.
There's that face there.
And then there's another
one coming out of the page,
I think.
OK.
So that's connectivity.
And the next thing are some
of these topological laws.
So the first one I'm
going to talk about
is called Euler's law.
If you remember Euler
from buckling, same guy.
So Euler's law relates the
number of vertices and faces
and cells and edges for
a large array of cells.
So we can relate the
total number of edges,
so I'm going to call that
E, vertices V, faces F,
and cells C. That
total number is
related by Euler's law for
a large aggregate of cells.
So in 2D Euler's law is
that the total number
of faces minus the
number of edges
plus the number of
vertices is equal to 1.
And in 3D, you just add a minus
the number of cells in front.
So minus the number of
cells, plus the number
of faces, minus the
number of edges,
plus the number of
vertices is equal to 1.
So there's some
interesting things
you can figure out
using Euler's law.
And one of the things
I wanted to look at
was if we had an
irregular honeycomb that
was three connected.
So say we have a
honeycomb that's not just
a regular hexagonal honeycomb,
or not even one that's
got repeating hexagonal cells.
But say we had a honeycomb
where some of the cells
had 5 sides to them, some of
them had 7, some of them had 6.
You can ask, what's the average
number of sides per face?
And you can use Euler's
law to figure that out.
So we're going to look at
an irregular three connected
honeycomb.
Let's see, I can
start that up here.
So when I say
irregular, I mean we've
got cells with different
numbers of sides.
So we have an irregular-- oops.
You OK, Greg?
--that is three connected.
And what is the average
number of sides per face?
And I'm going to
call that n bar.
So we're told that
it's three connected.
So that's saying that the
edge connectivity is 3.
So there's three edges
coming to each vertex.
So imagine that you had just
a regular hexagonal honeycomb,
like this.
Here's our vertex here.
And there's our kind of three
edges that come into it.
And each vertex is going to
have half of each edge, right?
Because the next
vertex-- each edge
is shared between two vertices.
So if Ze is equal to 3, then
the number of edges per vertex
is 3/2.
Because each edge is shared
between two vertices.
And I'm also going to define
something I'm going to call Fn.
And Fn is going to be the
number of faces with n sides.
So I could have some number
of the cells have six sides,
some number have five sides,
some number have seven sides.
So these are-- Fn is
the number of faces
with some particular
number of sides, n.
So if we have Fn is the
number of faces with n sides,
then if I sum up n times
Fn and divide it by 2,
that's the number of edges.
So imagine I have
all these faces.
I take n times Fn.
So say we had four
five-sided faces.
That would be four of those.
There's be 20 edges associated
with that, 20 sides.
Then I have some
number of six-sided,
some number of seven-sided.
I add them all up.
And I have to divide by 2
to get the number of edges,
because each edge
separates two faces.
OK.
And then I can use Euler's law.
So I can say F minus E
plus V is going to equal 1.
And here I've got an F minus
E plus-- I can put V here.
V's going to be 2/3 of
E. So I've got that.
So that's the same as F
minus 1/3 of E is equal to 1,
like that.
And then for E I can
substitute this thing here in.
So that gives me F minus 1/3
of the sum of n times Fn over 2
is equal to 1.
And then what I'm going to do
is multiply everything by 6
so I can get rid of
my denominator here.
So 6F minus sum of
nFn is going to be 6.
And then I'm going to
divide that through by F.
So that's 6 minus sum of
nFn over F is equal to 6/F.
And then if I let F go to
a large number-- so say
I've got a large
aggregate of cell.
I've got lots of faces.
I'm going to let F become large.
So if F becomes large, then
6/F is going to tend to 0.
Let me get the other rubber.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
LORNA GIBSON: Mhm?
AUDIENCE: That's-- F is like
the total number of faces,
not the total number
of faces per cell.
LORNA GIBSON: F is the
total number of faces.
And Fn is the number
of faces with n sides.
We've got some number with
5 sides, some number with 6,
some number with 7.
So we're almost at the end here.
So 6/F goes to 0.
And so that says that the
sum of n times Fn over F
is equal to 6.
And that just is n bar.
That is the average
number of sides per face.
This is your-- kind
of your total number
of sides in the whole thing.
And you're dividing by
the total number of faces.
So that is the average
number of sides per face.
So what this is
saying is if you have
a three connected honeycomb,
the average number
of sides per face is always 6.
So that if you introduce
a cell with 5 sides,
somewhere you have to
introduce a cell with 7 sides,
so that they compensate
and you come back out to 6.
And I have a little
soap bubble picture here
that kind of illustrates that.
So here we have
a soap honeycomb.
So you can make these
just by putting two glass
sheets close together
with a soap bubble froth
in between them.
And you can kind of see
in this picture here,
they've numbered how many sides
each cell or each face has.
So here's one with
5, here's one with 7.
And I'm not going to add
these up all together.
But you can kind of see
that the 5's and the 7's
kind of compensate
for each other,
and that the average
works out to about 6.
And this is true for a
large aggregate of cells.
So if you only have
a few, it's not
going to work out perfectly.
You need to have a large
aggregate to have it work.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And that
5, 7 balance doesn't
have to be touching, right?
LORNA GIBSON: No,
no, no, overall.
Yeah, overall.
And, you know, you could
have one with 4 sides,
and you'd need two 7's
or one 8 or something.
But you'd need to have that
balance out and match up.
OK.
So that's the Euler law.
Now there's a couple more
of these kinds of things.
There's something called
the Aboav-Weaire law.
And so the Aboav-Weaire is
sort of related to the Euler
because it's
looking at this idea
that if you have a three
connected honeycomb, if you
introduce a 5-sided cell,
you have to introduce
a 7-sided cell to compensate.
And what Aboav noticed
was that generally
cells with more
sides than average
have neighbors with
fewer sides than average.
Let's see.
So we'll say the introduction
of a 5-sided cell
requires the introduction
of a 7-sided cell.
And I'll just put-- this is
all for a 3 connected net, a 3
connected honeycomb.
So that generally, cells
with more sides than average
have neighbors with
fewer sides than average.
And in 3D, you could say the
same thing about the faces.
The cells that have more faces
than average have neighbors
with fewer faces than average.
So Aboav made
observations of this.
And it was Dennis Weaire
who made a proof of it.
And the equation that
they came up with
relates the average number of
sides in the cell surrounding
a candidate cell.
Let's see-- are we going to
be able to put it in here?
Maybe.
So say you have a candidate
cell and say it has n sides.
So you look at one particular
cell and you say, count up,
it's got n sides around it.
And then you count up the
number of sides of all the cells
surrounding it.
It has n neighbors
because it has n sides,
so then the average number
of sides of the n neighbors
is called m bar.
It has n sides.
So then the average number
of sides of its n neighbors
is m bar.
And m bar is equal to 5 plus
6 over n for a 2D honeycomb
kind of cell structure.
OK, so that's the
Aboav-Weaire law.
And then there's one
more of these things.
The last one is
called Lewis' rule.
And Lewis looked at biological
cells and 2D cell patterns,
and he found that
the area of the cell
varied linearly with
the number of the sides.
And he found just an
empirical relationship.
It looks like this.
We can say what
everything is in a minute.
So he found that the area of a
cell with n sides, that's A n,
was linearly related
to the number of sides,
so this n over here, and
naught's just a constant
and A n bar is the area of the
cell with the average number
of sides.
So here, A n is the area of
cells with n sides and A n bar.
And then n naught
is just a constant.
And he found that for 2D
cells n naught was equal to 2.
And if you look at
voronoi honeycombs--
remember last time we
talked about those voronoi
honeycombs-- you
can show that this
holds for voronoi honeycombs.
And then you could write a
3D version of this as well.
And in 3D, it's the volume
and faces instead of the areas
and the number of sides.
So you can say that the
volume of the cells with f
faces relative to the
volumes of the cells
with the average
number of faces,
they vary linearly with
the number of faces.
So there's sort of an exactly
analogous expression here.
And here, this f naught
is another constant.
And in 3D it's about equal to 3.
So these are all just kind of
interesting topological rules
that are nice to know about.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Basic question.
In two dimensions,
what is a face?
Like what does that refer to?
LORNA GIBSON: So-- and let me
put my little slides again.
So say we have some
honeycombs like this, then
say we look at this guy.
So that's a vertex
there, that's an edge,
and this thing in the
middle here is the face.
So in 2D, the face and the
cell is kind of the same thing.
All right?
And then--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] sides,
what's different with the edge?
LORNA GIBSON: It's not quite.
Like if I count up
the number of edges,
I say one, two,
three, four, five,
and I count those up like that.
But if I say sides of the
face-- see that's a face
or it's a cell-- I would
say that had six sides.
Right?
So typically when people
say it has-- a cell
or a face has so many sides,
they count up how many
all around it.
But because each side
is-- or each edge
is-- shared between two
faces, the number of edges
is actually half that.
Right?
Because there's one edge, but if
I count up the number of sides
for this face and I count up the
number of sides for that face,
I'm counting that twice.
So it's a little bit--
so I try to see edges
when I'm talking about
adding them all up
and I try to say sides
when I'm talking about,
here's a face, how many
sides does it have.
OK?
It's a little bit confusing.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what is n bar naught?
LORNA GIBSON: n bar naught,
did I put an n bar naught?
Oh, that's where I
didn't erase this enough.
There you go.
It's just n naught.
OK.
So we've been talking
about the structure
of the honeycombs in the foams.
And what we
ultimately want to do
is be able to model
the mechanical behavior
or the thermal behavior,
some sort of behavior
of the cellular material.
And for looking at
mechanical behavior,
there's three main
approaches that people take.
So you have to model
the structure somehow.
So there's three
main approaches.
And the first one is
to use the unit cell.
So say, for example,
for the honeycombs,
if you have a hexagonal
honeycomb you'd just
use that unit hexagonal cell.
And that's what we're going
to do probably starting later
on today.
So for the hexagonal honeycomb,
it's kind of obvious.
You would use a unit cell,
the thing's periodic,
you figure out how that unit
cell behaves, you're all set.
For a foam, it was not so
obvious a unit cell to use.
But the thing-- people
use different things,
but one of the common ones they
use is a tetrakaidecahedron.
So the nice thing about
the tetrakaidecahedron
is that it packs to fill space.
So it's a repeating single cell.
Packs to fill space.
But, in fact, real foams
aren't tetrakaidecahedrons,
so this is a bit
of an idealization.
So we'll just say foam cells
are not tetrakaidecahedrons.
OK, so that's one approach.
And then a second approach
is to use something
called dimensional analysis.
So in dimensional
analysis, what you
want to do here,
with this technique,
is model the mechanisms
of deformation and failure
in the structure.
But you don't necessarily
represent the cell geometry
exactly.
And so what you do
is, you say one thing
is proportional to
another and there's
some constant of
proportionality,
and you just wrap all of those
constants of proportionality up
at the end.
So for instance, when
people look at foams,
the geometry of the foams
is kind of complicated.
There's cells with
different number of faces,
there's different sizes of
cells, it's kind of a mess.
So we could just say
the geometry is complex
and it's difficult to model.
And with dimensional
analysis, instead what we do
is we model the deformation
mechanisms and failure
mechanisms.
And you can get quite a bit
out of just modeling those.
So when we look at modeling
foams, we're going to do this,
and you'll see how it works.
And then the third method is
to use finite element analysis.
So this is a numerical
technique and it's a very
standard numerical technique.
And one of the nice
things about this
is you can apply it
to random structures.
So for example, those
voronoi structures
we saw, if you want
to try to see--
say you had a certain
amount of material
and you had a honeycomb that was
a regular hexagonal honeycomb.
You had the same
amount of material
and you put it in a
voronoi honeycomb,
and you want to know how does
having a random material affect
the properties relative
to the uniform material?
You could figure that out
using finite element analysis.
So you can apply it
to random structures.
And another thing you can do
with finite element analysis--
and people in the
orthopedics end of the world
often do this-- if you're
interested in trabecular bone,
that porous type of bone I
showed you the first day,
people can take micro-computed
tomography images of trabecular
bone and they get a file which
basically says, every voxel,
says if it's solid or it's void.
And you can use
those files as input
to a finite element analysis.
And so you can analyze exactly
how a piece of a trabecular
bone would deform.
So it's nice for that.
So one of the things we're
going to talk about later
is we'll look at the
structure of trabecular bone
and the sort of mechanics
of trabecular bone,
and I'll show you some results
that a former student of mine
did, where we look
at-- say you have
a sort of intact structure
of a certain density
and then you reduce the density
by fitting the cell walls
or you reduce the density by
removing cell walls-- because
in osteoporosis sometimes the
walls resorb all together--
and you can see what
residual strength you
would have for some given
amount of density loss.
So it's good for looking
at that kind of a thing.
You can also use it for
looking at local effects.
So you can look at
defects, for instance.
So if you think of
the trabecular bone
as having missing
trabeculae, that
would be a defect
in the structure.
You can look at that.
You can look at size effects.
So when we were studying some of
those metal foams, some of them
have very large
cells, and if you
have a small sample
relative to the cell size,
you may only have four or five
cells across the dimension.
Where you've cut
the cells, you've
got edges that are
less constrained
than in the bulk of the material
because at the outer edge
you've cut them.
They're not connected
to anything else.
And so you can look at edge
effects that relate to the size
effects in foams as well.
So these are basically
the three approaches
that people use for
modeling cellular materials.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to start with
looking at honeycombs
and we're going to look at these
hexagonal kind of honeycombs
like this.
And one reason to
start with them
is that they have this
unit cell structure.
And if you can analyze how that
unit cell deforms and fails,
you can say something
about the whole structure.
And it turns out
that the honeycombs,
they deform and fail by the
same mechanisms as the foams.
So if you can understand
through this simple structure,
it gives you a lot of insight
into how the foams behave.
So if I deform this a little
bit, the cell walls bend.
And you can show that if you
deform this guy a little bit,
the cell walls bend.
And so you can learn a lot
by looking at the honeycombs
and then sort of applying
that to the foams.
So we're going to
start off-- so that's
the end of the section
on sort of the structure
of the cellular
materials-- and now we're
going to look at modeling
the mechanical properties
and we're going to start
with the honeycombs
and then we're
going to do foams.
So when we talk
about the honeycombs,
we've got this
hexagonal structure here
and we're going
to call properties
in this plane the
in-plane property.
So if I load it this
way on or that way on,
those are in-plane, and
if I load it that way on,
those are out of plane.
So think of the cells
are in the plane
and the prismatic direction
is the out of plane.
And clearly, the
honeycombs are going
to have similar properties
this way and that way,
but they are going to have very
different properties that way.
So we're going to start
with the in-plane behavior.
So the honeycombs have
these prismatic cells
and they're widely available in
different materials, polymers,
metals, ceramics.
And they're used in a
variety of applications.
So one of the most common is
to use them in sandwich panels.
So I brought a couple of
sandwich panels with me today.
So here's a couple
of sandwich panels
that have honeycomb cores.
This one's an aircraft
flooring panel.
It's got carbon fiber faces and
a Nomex core, honeycomb core.
And this is an
aluminum honeycomb.
It's got aluminum honeycomb
core and then aluminum faces,
and it's kind of amazing how
stiff that little panel is.
And each of the pieces is
really not that stiff at all,
but the thing put
together is quite stiff,
and we'll talk more about that
when we get to sandwich panels.
So it's used in sandwich panels.
They're used for
energy absorption.
So sometimes you'll see there's
some natural disaster area
and they fly in
helicopters and they
drop big crates of
supplies, and they
will have it like a pallet
with a big crate thing.
Often they have a honeycomb,
like a metal honeycomb, that
is kind of oriented this way.
So the pallet would be like this
and the honeycomb's like that.
And the idea is that
when they drop it--
they sort of bring it down
as close as they can--
and then the
honeycomb absorbs some
of the energy from the impact.
And they're also used, I think,
sometimes in car bumpers.
So they're used for
energy absorption.
And they're used as
carriers for catalysts.
So the catalytic
converter in your car
looks like this, this is
kind of the material that's
used in the catalytic
converter in your car.
And the way that works is, the
cell walls here are actually
porous and they're coated
in the platinum, which
is the catalyst, and
half of the cells
are blocked off on this end.
So every other cell on
this end is blocked off
and then every other cell
over here, the opposite ones,
are blocked off.
And so the gas is
forced down a channel
but then through the wall and
then out the next channel.
And that's where the
reaction actually occurs,
is in the cell wall.
So they're used
as carriers there.
And some natural materials
also have a cellular structure,
have a honeycomb structure.
So for example, things
like woods and cork
have a honeycomb structure, too.
So I said the mechanisms
of deformation and failure
in the hexagonal honeycombs
parallel those in foams.
So we can learn
a lot about foams
by understanding the honeycombs.
And then, similarly,
the mechanisms
of deformation and failure
in triangulated honeycombs
parallel those in the
lattice materials.
Remember I brought those
lattice materials in?
The sort of trust
type materials.
The triangular honeycombs
have a behavior
similar to those
lattice materials.
OK.
So let me scoot over here.
So let me scoot out of this one.
OK.
So here is our kind
of hexagonal geometry.
This is kind of an
idealized geometry here.
And, as we talked about in
this section on the structure,
we're going to call
these vertical walls,
we're going to say
they have a length h,
the inclined walls have a length
l, the wall thickness is t,
and there's going to be an angle
between the horizontal and that
inclined wall of theta.
And I'm going to
define three axes here,
an x1, an x2, and an x3 axis.
So the x1, x2 plane is
the in-plane and x3 is out
of plane.
OK?
So if we load our
honeycomb up, we
get stress strain curves
that look like this.
So the ones on the left
here, over here these three
are all in compression,
and the ones on the right,
these three are all in tension.
OK, so let's talk about
the compression ones first.
And let's start at the top.
This is in elastomeric
material, so
like one of these
rubber honeycombs.
This would be a material
that yields plastically,
so like an aluminum honeycomb.
And this would be a honeycomb
that fails in a brittle manner,
like one of those
ceramic honeycombs.
OK?
So if we go up to
the elastomeric one,
up here, if I compress it I get
a linear elastic part first,
and then at some point,
I get a stress plateau
where the stress is almost
constant for strains
that are quite large.
And then finally,
the stress starts
to rise quite sharply
at the end here.
So the strain here
goes from 0 to 1.
So that's a strain of 100%.
You've completely
flattened the thing there.
So that's a large strain.
So initially, when we're
loading it up to smaller strains
like this, we've got linear
elastic behavior and these cell
walls bend.
And you can relate
the modulus here--
let's see where'd
my little arrow go--
you can relate this Young's
modulus here to the bending
of those cell walls.
And we're going
to-- I don't know
if we'll finished that today--
but we'll start that today.
Then-- oops, lost my
arrow, where'd my arrow
go-- then at the
stress plateau here,
that plateau is related
to collapse of the cells.
So if I have my little
rubber honeycomb
and I load it, at some
point, the cell walls buckle.
So you see how
they've buckled there?
And that stress plateau,
I can smush that
to quite large strains that
are roughly constant stress.
OK?
So what's happening here is
that we're buckling the cells.
And as we go along here,
the buckling deformation
gets bigger and bigger.
And then if I smush it and
I've got it kind of like that,
at some point it becomes
much harder to press it
together again because the
cell walls are now touching
each other and they're
pressing against themselves,
and to get a certain
amount of strain,
it gets much more
difficult to do that.
And the stress required to
do that gets much bigger.
And that's what leads to this
last piece of the stress strain
curve here, which is called
densification because you've
almost eliminated the pores.
It's hard to eliminate
them entirely
but the porosity
has gone way down
by the time you're up there.
So this type of
stress strain curve
where you've got linear
elasticity and then
a stress plateau and
then the densification
is classic for compressive
behavior of cellular materials.
So elastomeric ones will
have a plateau that's
related to elastic buckling.
I lost my arrow again.
There we go.
If we had a metal
honeycomb, we'd
again have linear elasticity
related to cell wall bending.
This plateau here
would be related
to yielding of the cell walls.
So say we had
aluminum honeycomb,
the aluminum could yield,
and that would again
cause this stress plateau.
And then we get densification.
If I had a brittle honeycomb
like the ceramic one,
we'd have initial
linear elasticity.
Then you've got a
stress plateau that's
kind of a lot of
up and down here.
And the serrated nature
is related to the fracture
of individual cell walls.
So it goes up and down because
when you break a cell wall,
the stress drops off, and then
the other cell walls will try
to pick the stress up again.
And so each one of those
little up and downs
corresponds to
breaking a cell wall.
But if you kind of took
an average of that,
you can see there's
a stress plateau
and then there's the
densification region.
So in compression, the shape
of the curves is very similar
and the mechanism of the
plateau varies a little bit.
So let's see if I can
write some of that down.
So in compression, we can say we
have three regimes of behavior.
So we've got the linear
elastic regime initially
and we're going to see that's
related to cell wall bending.
Oh, thanks.
And then we've got
a stress plateau.
And for elastomeric
materials, that's
caused by buckling of the walls.
For metals, it would
be caused by yielding.
And for ceramics, it would be
caused by a brittle crushing.
And then we've
got densification.
And that's related to
the cell walls touching.
And if we increase the ratio of
the thickness of the cell walls
relative to their
length, we're going
to increase the
stiffness, so the Young's
modulus of the honeycomb.
The stress plateau I'm
going to call sigma star.
And we decrease
the strain at which
that densification occurs, which
I'm going to call epsilon D.
So you see over on the right
hand side of these plots
here, that strain there is the
densification strain, epsilon
D. So that's in compression.
And these materials are very
often loaded in compression.
In tension, we still get
linear elasticity initially.
And that's going to,
again, be related
to the bending of
the cell walls.
But if we look at
the stress plateau,
if you look at these three
curves here on the right,
the stress plateau only exists
if the material has a yield
point and you get some
plastic yielding there.
If you have an elastomer,
if I pull on this--
you don't get
buckling in tension,
so you're not going to get
a stress plateau in tension.
And for a brittle
material like one
of those brittle honeycombs, if
you pull that in tension, you
would just get a crack
propagate and the thing would
break into two pieces and so
you don't get a stress plateau
there.
So the stress plateau
in tension only
exists if the material yields.
So you don't get any
buckling in tension.
And for a brittle honeycomb,
you would just get fracture.
OK?
These inclined walls
are going to bend.
We're going to see that in
more gory detail in one minute.
If you can wait one minute.
OK.
So are we good with a
stress strain curves yet?
AUDIENCE: More of an
abstract question,
but is it possible [INAUDIBLE]
to get collapse this way
before the plateau?
LORNA GIBSON: I
haven't seen that.
But maybe it it's
possible, I don't know.
I don't think so, but maybe.
Anybody else?
OK.
OK, so here's some
photographs of honeycombs.
So these ones are white but
these ones are just the same.
So most of them are just a
regular hexagonal honeycomb
and one of them is this
funny shaped honeycomb here.
These two guys at the top,
these two here, are unloaded.
And then the rest of
them have some loading.
So if you look at this
one down here-- so here
I'm taking the honeycomb
and I'm loading it.
This is the x1
direction, that way on.
And if you look
very carefully, you
can see what happens is
these vertical walls just
move sideways and
that is going to zoot,
with the sound effects.
And then the-- I can't
help making sound effects--
and then these guys here bend.
OK, so this guy here--
it's maybe a little hard
to see it on the image
but it's actually
a little bit bent there.
So that's loading
it this way on.
And then similarly, if I take
it and I load it that way on,
that's the x2 direction.
And now these guys
here, the vertical guys,
are just going to
compress a little.
But these guys here,
the incline guys,
are still going to
bend a little bit.
And I've got some
schematics that's
going to show that
a little bit better.
And then if I shear it, if
I took it like this and I--
I can't do it because my hands
aren't glued to the rubber--
but if I could sort of
shear it this way on,
then you would get this
kind of deformation here
and that also involves bending.
You can imagine
these guys here would
bend if I do that to them.
And then the buckling
deformation looks like this.
If I scooch that like
that, it should look kind
of like that picture there.
OK?
So that's kind of what
the deformation looks
like for these
sorts of honeycombs.
So these were elastomer rubbers.
These are just some images
from an aluminum honeycomb.
So here's, the top one's
the undeformed honeycomb,
the middle one's loading
it in the one direction
from left to right,
and the bottom one's
loading it in the two direction
from top and bottom like that.
OK?
So you can imagine that
you've got little cell walls.
If you load it up high enough,
those walls are going to yield
and we're going to see that
the yielding in the walls
causes the formation
of something
called plastic hinges
and the walls can rotate
and they can produce
these kind of shapes.
OK.
So then this is sort of a
schematic stress strain curve
here.
And this is showing what
happens if you increase
the thickness of the walls
relative to the length,
or you increase the
relative density,
you increase the volume
per action of solids.
And this kind of shows
the different regimes.
So over here-- well
let's, first of all,
start with the different
relative density.
So this one here is the
lowest relative density,
then this is higher,
and higher, and higher.
And not too surprisingly,
the more you
increase the density,
the more material
you've got, the stiffer it is,
the stronger it's going to be.
And the more
material you've got,
the sooner it's
going to densify.
If you've got more
solid in here,
you're going to reach
that densification
strain at a smaller number.
OK, so the shape of the
curves looks like this.
And you can define these
three kind of regimes.
So everything in here
is linear elastic,
everything in this
big sort of envelope
here is the plateau region,
and everything up here
is this densification region.
So this is just a bigger
picture kind of plot.
OK, so let me skip
through all of that.
All right.
OK, where are we?
Chalk?
Here we go.
OK, so I think I mentioned
this before, but let
me just go over it again.
So there's three
types of things that
affect the properties,
the mechanical properties,
of the honeycombs.
And probably the
most important thing
is the relative density
of the honeycomb.
So remember, we said this
was the same as the volume
fraction of solids, and
for a hexagonal honeycomb,
you can show that's equal to
the thickness to length ratio
times h over l plus 2 divided
by 2 cos theta times h over l
plus sin theta.
And if you have regular
hexagons, so h over l
is equal to 1, all the
sides are of equal length,
theta is equal to 30
degrees, the relevant density
is 2 over 3 times t over l.
So it just goes
linearly with t over l.
The thickness to length
ratio of the walls.
So it depends on how
much solid you've got.
Depends on the solid properties.
So the Young's modulus of
the solid, yield strength
if it's a metal, some
sort of fracture strength
if it's brittle.
It also depends on
the cell geometry,
which we can describe
with h over l and theta.
So if we think of a cell here--
that's our edge length h,
that's our edge length l,
that's our angle theta,
here's the cell
wall thickness t,
and then we've got some set
of solid properties here.
OK?
So that's kind of the set up.
And we're going to define
x1, x2 axes like that.
And we're going to make
a few assumptions just
to make life a
little bit simpler.
So we're going to assume
that t over l is small,
so that also means the
relative density is small.
And what that
means is that we're
going to be able to neglect
axial and shear deformations.
So you can imagine,
if I have a thin wall
and I'm applying loads that
produce moments and produce
bending, if the wall
is very thin then
the axial and the
shear deformations
are going to be small.
I'm also going to assume
the deformations are small.
And what that means
is that I'm going
to neglect any changes in
the geometry of the cell
during the deformation.
And I'm going to assume that the
cell wall is linear, elastic,
and isotropic.
And we're going to
start off with looking
at in-plane behavior,
and we're going
to start with the
elastic moduli.
And if we look at
the elastic moduli,
we're going to be talking
about Hooke's law.
And Hooke's law and the elastic
behavior of the material
can be described by a
set of elastic constants.
And if you recall, the number of
independent elastic constants,
how many constants you need
to describe the material,
depends on its symmetry.
And these materials
are orthotropic.
So the regular
hexagonal honeycomb
is actually
transversely isotropic,
but imagine that h
was not equal to l,
then it would be orthotropic.
So remember, orthotropic
means that you
can rotate the structure 180
degrees about three mutually
perpendicular axes and the
structure looks the same.
So if I take this and I do
that, it looks the same,
and if I do that, it looks
the same, if I-- no matter how
I rotate this, about three
mutually perpendicular axes,
the structure remains unchanged.
So it's orthotropic.
So I'm going to write
down Hooke's law
for our orthotropic
material, and then we'll
talk about the constants
that we're going to work out.
OK, so this is Hooke's law
for our orthotropic material.
And let me just remind you
what our notation is here.
So epsilon 1 is epsilon 1 1.
Epsilon 2 is epsilon 2 2.
Epsilon 3 is epsilon 3 3.
Epsilon 4 is gamma 2 3.
Epsilon 5 is gamma 1 3.
And epsilon 6 is gamma 1 2.
So these are the normal strains
here, epsilon 1, 2, and 3,
and these are the shear strains
here, epsilon 4, 5, and 6.
And you remember this convention
where the subscripts add up
to 9.
So 4 plus 2 plus 3 is
9, 5 plus 1 plus 3 is
9, 6 plus 1 plus 2 is 9.
And then the stresses
are a similar thing.
So sigma 1, sigma 2, and sigma
3 are the normal stresses.
And then sigma 4, sigma 5, and
sigma 6 are the shear stresses.
And for the in-plane
moduli, so we're
dealing with the x1,
x2 plane, there's
four independent
elastic constants.
So we could think of it as
E1, E2, a Poisson's ratio 1 2
and a shear modulus
in the 1 2 plane.
OK?
And the compliance
matrix is symmetric,
so there's the reciprocal
relationship between the moduli
and the Poisson's ratios.
And then the notation I'm going
to use for Poisson's ratio,
I'm going to say
that mu i j is minus
the ratio of the strain
in the j direction divided
by the strain in
the i direction.
OK.
So what we're
going to do next is
we're going to calculate
some of the elastic moduli.
I'm going to show you the
derivation for E1 star
and mu 1 2 star, and you can get
the other two in a similar way.
So I'm not going
to do all of them
but next time we'll do the
derivations for the Young's
modulus in the Poisson's ratio.
OK?
And then we're going to
talk about the out of plane
direction later and we'll get
the moduli for the out of plane
direction as well.
OK?
So I think I'm going to
stop there for today.
And then we'll start doing
the derivations next time.